[Music]
it's currently 629 he's the darkest of
nights outside
families creating okay I got deal with
that
okay shorter walk it's currently 39 or
Kikuyu y'all go to camera beautiful this
is my meal delivery then I'm not
sponsored by them for any reason I just
do it because they can hit certain
macros it's awfully nice because I don't
often have time to cook myself a meal so
I do that instead he's dork
my back is hurting me for some reason I
must have been overtraining cuz like my
upper shoulder muscles are real tight so
I'm gonna take it easy on working out
today yeah
just the way it is right now it really
looks like someone's standing back there
doesn't it I guarantee you no one's
standing back there say I told you it's
not it's not someone that exists away go
you know the drill I go work out you
stay here because girl card the house I
got me Luger you've heard the house do
we have a deal can deal we made the deal
this I'll see you at the gym I just got
to the gym I'm gonna keep the spooky
lighting because I like it it's an
American nice there's like that the Bond
villain look to it I work out with Alex
hybrid wellness if you've been watching
him it's honest you know who alex is
he's a cool guy and he's really good
personal trainer and he's been helping
me get in shape so I'm gonna tell him
about my shoulder problem on that back
problem so don't expect any like
spectacular workout video with this but
I'm gonna be in here for an hour session
it's just about seven o'clock he's
probably wondering where I am something
to get in there okay cool see you dudes
Alex by the way he's got a YouTube
channel hey how it's steaming
[Music]
[Applause]
all right it's uh oops I didn't cancel
my workout this is about what mmm [ __ ]
off Siri this is about what I did
[ __ ] off Siri this is about what I do
not too bad today pretty slow here's my
paragraph for anyone that gives us okay
it's gone what is it with my phone
that's that's about what I did so oh my
god always brings a toy every time I
have to get showered and then I have to
record a vlog because I got
pepper-sprayed and by the time you'll
see this you'll already know because I
will have already made the vlog but I'm
just gonna make a video talking about
that because that was an intense
experience and you already know that
because you watched the video but I I
haven't recorded it yet so there's a
weird before time after time kind of
thing time travel thing so I'm gonna go
get a shower I'm gonna get to work on
that I need I don't know why I don't
have a tripod for my phone I still have
this pain in my shoulder but I'm gonna
go see Alex again about four o'clock to
either jump in the cryotherapy or it's
an acupuncture
I'm still to this day like not a huge
believer in acupuncture so this will be
like the first time I've actually gone
in for treatment but hey it's a weird
day huh with the rain and the getting up
late in the daylight savings time so
anyway I do love this smell it reminds
me of my dad because he he loved the
coffee making process he loved Folgers
coffee he had the same tub all the time
I just remember very distinctly even as
a kid I was never allowed to have coffee
but I loved just that smell
today is pax apparently
[Music]
as very hot
hmm yeah so I drink my coffee black I'm
not by choice I think you should say
like at least some cream or a lot of
cream but I've been doing intermittent
fasting Alex has prescribed it to me and
it's been working incredibly effectively
so I won't have breakfast
I only from noon to 8:00 and then I try
to keep it around 2,000 calories a day
which those meals they help out a lot
because I'm trying to hit a certain
amount of protein so that I can keep up
my muscle or I can build muscle I'm not
going for body builder but it's just a
really convenient meal when I'm on the
go so in addition to the coffee I are
supposed to drink a gallon and a half of
water a day
which would be
six of these obviously I haven't been
doing it because I wouldn't know that
off the top of my head that wouldn't
have to think about that oh well you're
getting a lot of these shots because I
literally don't have a tripod why do I a
youtuber not have a tripod for my phone
I've got a tripod for my camera
not for my phone no it's currently eight
thirty seven so I have plenty of time to
make this video and then today's Tuesday
suit today's podcast day so I'm going to
get ready to podcast with the boys Bob
and Wade we're gonna play some games on
Twitch if you don't know about it we do
it pretty much every Tuesday we haven't
for the best few weeks just because
people have been out for various reasons
but we're back in it again for the 36th
time so today's podcast day but before
that I'm going to enjoy these cup of
coffee all right so right now I'm up in
my office is 855 took some time with my
coffee answered a few emails right now
I'm just waiting for footage from
Alexian so in the meantime let me use my
time wisely and I'm going to practice
juggling which is what I've been doing
for march usamos every day I try to get
in at least 10 minutes yesterday I did
not get my practice in so I'm gonna just
practice until 9:00 okay
juggling all done I'm still waiting on
the video but it is 9:30 for Siri why
was wrong with you okay anyway now that
that nightmare is over its 9:30 for
juggling is done but I gotta get moving
on this vlog because if I want to get it
done and uploaded before I start
streaming which is essential I gotta get
going right now so I'm gonna work on
that I'll message you once I get to the
editing phase mmm okay so running a
little short on time it's 1006 I just
made to banger thumbnails this one and
oh god no why don't I have a drop but
this one in this one oh yeah
so made those need to make the vlog now
I got a hurry I try to make it as easy
as possible I'm gonna try to do the
cameras which is on my little dough got
Oh yep you've already seen the video so
if it came out okay then it came out
okay if it didn't
then I screwed up timeout haha okay I
just finished recording the video I did
it as easy as possible so I need to edit
it upload it and then make sure the
pepper-spray video for who's honest is
up and ready to go so a lot of work to
be done before I am ready for the stream
I've got about 35 minutes to do it in
but that should be just enough time I
might be just a little late on the
stream but that's pretty usual for me
anyway so anyway alright I'm gonna get
to it I just finished editing the video
it is rendering should be done in about
4 minutes 20 seconds the thumbnails
already done I just need to get it
uploading hopefully gets done uploading
before I need to start streaming
anyway video doesn't have any music cuz
I didn't feel like going to the effort
doing that and also it doesn't really
need it sister look this is an update
and my voice is nice enough by itself so
there you'll okay just got done with a
stream of that was another three and a
half hours is currently 236 so doing
pretty good I'm gonna get some more food
in me and then I'm going to probably
relax for a little bit and then I need
to get over to Alex at 4 to get my
treatment either acupuncture or
cryotherapy I know but it needs it
because that whole stream my shoulder
was just bugging me the whole time but
gotta keep moving 3 o'clock on the dot
just drop my my snack didn't team or my
dad introduced this to me when I was
like 5 years old and I've been eating it
ever since love it it's good I doubt the
recipes changed it's probably terrible
for you but hey you know foods food it
kind of looks like ass but it tastes
amazing
so just like ass we're gonna take the
pups out for a walk real quick while
it's not reading and hopefully it
doesn't rain on us
[Music]
okay it started raining on the way back
it is currently 3:23 I'm gonna go down
early to Alex because he said it was
pretty free today so I'm just gonna go
down there now bye Amy I will when you
put Bow Wow
one can only hope
alright buddy ah nevermind [ __ ] that
Jesus where did that come from
Amy's really random it's 3:24 nevermind
not going out really rainin
all right acupuncture time the pit I
have the needles in me they are running
a current through my arm to try to
alleviate this pain first time doing
this Tyler had this yeah
help Disney real good yeah real good all
right just got done needles are out and
also he did a little cupping stone I
actually got the cupping mark but for
real this time feels way better feels
way better okay
I'm home and now I'm gonna leave again
because there's a bike shop and I've
been meaning to get my bike fixed up so
what better day than today to get my
bike fixed and I've got some free time
so I'm gonna go do that also my arm
feels better okay
it is for 53 and I got a new bike shoes
which I don't need for my bike I needed
for the peloton which I've started doing
which is actually a good workout and I'm
not actually do tonight because it
doesn't involve my shoulder I usually do
two workouts a day so I'm gonna go home
get these set up and ready to go and
then go for uh maybe a tough ride don't
know
I took it really easy this morning so I
probably should push myself on my bike's
dropped off I'm not gonna get that back
for another day or two just because it's
end of the day today and they give it a
once-over back home oh my god you're not
gonna believe this
I'm not I don't I don't believe this so
this thing is the part that's been on my
bike in the garage for like two years I
haven't written in ages I looked inside
here cuz it feels like something's in
here my [ __ ] Nintendo switch that I
lost or thought I lost for ages and ages
I did not know where this was it's in my
bike bag why I have no idea boy I guess
it doesn't matter so I found that great
okay I was gonna go bike on the peloton
but I'm hungry so many dinner first
it's another macro player here's your
turkey burrito bowl not exciting not
exciting at all Eddie is excited oh he's
scared I'm sorry
come here Andy I'm sorry is just a
burrito bowl at yuca okay it's exactly
six o'clock a little late getting into
this and took my time with dinner but
I'm gonna hit a 45-minute bike ride this
is the peloton if you want to know story
I am the guy from that commercial that
got his girlfriend
they belted for Christmas that was me a
year and a half ago and hey everything
worked out right Amy hey you know how I
got you this poem for Christmas and you
loved me all the more for it all the
same that's good right
okay okay I'm in my undies
about 150 145 I like to go the first 20
minutes hard then slow it down for this
second biking's hard
[Music]
[Applause]
not bad not bad not bad
all done he's doing ring fit my watch
does you who are wondering yes I do take
two showers and yes most days I do
workout twice a day at least now that is
a new occurrence and yes it means I do a
lot of laundry and it sucks but that's
the reality if you want to get fit yeah
fit
[Music]
wanna know how to get perfectly cooked
eggs every time large Japan no more than
four eggs once it starts to get a little
solid around the edges of water in it
blows lid steam will cook the top you
never need to flip it and you'll get
some nice its edge crispy edges is
horrible once the tops of the yolks just
start to get cloudy don't lift the lid
that one's just starting to get cloudy
over there move from the heat turn off
it was that medium by the way and just
let the steam cook the rest of it once
it's done every yolk will be cloudy and
that means the top egg white also will
get cooked and then well it plays I
didn't plate it right but four perfectly
cooked eggs
no flipping season how do I do this
oh god here we go Jesus Christ just
Jason Bourne sprinkle of salt splatter
and me I like to ruin it no one judge me
on this BLAP BLAP BLAP BLAP Frank's
redhot baby I realized I haven't
actually filmed myself eating something
why I was awful oh I almost died
this is cursed mmm all right now because
I have some extra calories
hi and we're going to have a little bit
of ice cream some a low top Oh we'd be
something with cone bits in it I love
American dream Oh God if they could
bring a butter pecan into a little
butter pecan it's my favorite flavor
Hilla top call me please call me having
calm age you can't call me directly I
will not answer the phone okay it's
currently 7:50 the only thing I have
left to do is I need to check a video
from the editor for Miss honest to make
sure that it's okay for tomorrow that's
like the last thing I have to get done
now I could
this video's sake be like oh yeah I'm
gonna get XYZ done but I kind of want
this to be an authentic day I'm not
gonna just go to bed after this but my
bedtime is 10 o'clock so I'm probably
just gonna practice some more juggling
watch a couple videos and then I'll
probably hit bed that's about it for me
so once I get this done I'm going to
update you on what I do next cuz okay
it's 847 um I just had to give some
notes back and do some organizational
things for when it's honest and then
then I have to schedule some meetings
for tomorrow like six hours of mission
but meetings have to happen because
people need to know what's going on for
various things I'm getting pretty tired
I think I'm pretty tapped out for the
day the most I'm gonna do after this is
a little bit of juggling practice but
overall today was a good day this is a
slightly above average day for me but
this is actually pretty average I try to
workout twice a day I tried to get some
recording done I tried to get a little
editing done but less and less these
days and then you know at the other
small projects take care am i eating
take care of myself and then taking care
of the dogs those are pretty much my
priorities okay cool next transition
that I do brush my teeth
oh it's 9:46 it is time for bed
I'm going to sleep and for everyone
watching thank you this has been my day
it's pretty typical sometimes there'll
be more meetings sometimes will be more
out and about filming but he'd stay
pretty much that busy but this was a
good day got a lot done better than that
it's bedtime so I'm gonna sleep so Lexi
I'm just give me some like nice dreams
or something Kimmy here's sweet dreams
yeah I sleep with light on whatever it's
okay just something nice definitely not
horrible nightmares still do that
[Music]